before we get into the terms endo and
exothermic we need to look at some other
thermodynamics terms that are used for
example system the system refers to the
part of the universe that we are
studying for our example we're going to
consider a monatomic gas let's say we
have some helium particles in a
container and the helium gas
represents our system
the surroundings are everything else in
the universe so that would include this
piston here and and the cylinder and
which the gas is in
and the universe consists of both the
system and the surroundings
next let's look at the first law of
thermodynamics which can be summarized
by writing delta e is equal to q plus w
delta e is the change in the internal
energy of the system and the internal
energy refers to the sum of all the
kinetic and potential energies of the
components of the system since we have a
monatomic gas for our system we only
have kinetic energy so if you could
imagine adding up the kinetic energy for
each particle the sum of those kinetic
energies for this example would be equal
to the internal energy of the system
q refers to the heat that's transferred
from the system so it's either
transferred uh it's either transferred
to or from the system and w refers to
the work done on or by the system
let's look at the sign conventions for
the first law of thermodynamics when we
think about q when heat flows into the
system from the surroundings we say that
q is positive
when heat flows out of the system and
into the surroundings we say that q is
negative
for work when work is done on the system
by the surroundings the work is positive
but if work is done by the system on the
surroundings work is
negative
it's very useful to think about internal
energy like a bank account so if q is
positive and work is positive that's
like money coming into your bank account
but if q is negative or the work is
negative that's like money leaving your
bank account
let's look at an example of the first
law of thermodynamics using our sample
of helium that's in a cylinder with a
movable piston
so let's say that 6 000 joules of energy
so 6 000 joules
flows from the surroundings into the
system
and that heats up our helium particles
which then expand and push the piston up
so the piston gets pushed up which is
the system doing work on the
surroundings
and let's say that that's 2 000 joules
of work done
by the system on the surroundings
using our sign conventions since heat
flowed into the system from the
surroundings that's a positive value for
q
and since the work was done
by the system on the surroundings that's
a negative for the work done so we can
go ahead and plug into the first law of
thermodynamics
the heat transfer is positive 6 000
joules
and the work done is negative
2 000
joules
therefore delta e or the change in the
internal energy
is equal to positive
4
000 joules
thinking about internal energy like our
bank account we've gained 4 000 joules
so that could be like gaining four
thousand dollars since the system has
gained 4 000 joules that must mean the
surroundings has lost 4 000 joules but
since energy is conserved the total
energy of the universe remains constant
let's apply the first law of
thermodynamics to the combustion of
propane in an open container at constant
pressure for the combustion of propane
the reactants and products for the
combustion reaction are considered to be
the system and everything else is the
surroundings
so this combustion reaction gives off
2044 kilojoules of energy so that's the
heat that's transferred from the system
to the surroundings the system also does
two kilojoules of work on the
surroundings so by convention we make
that negative
to find the change in the internal
energy of the system we add q plus w and
get negative 2046
kilojoules
since this reaction was carried out
under constant external pressure we can
write q sub p here so q
sub p
is the heat that's transferred at
constant pressure and that is equal to
the change in the enthalpy which is
symbolized by delta h
so the change in enthalpy is the heat
that's transferred at constant pressure
so the change in enthalpy for the
combustion of propane is equal to
negative
2044 kilojoules and notice how the
change in enthalpy is almost the same
value as the change in the internal
energy so the work done by the system is
a very small amount in this case and
that's usually the case and since most
chemical reactions are done under
constant pressure chemists care more
about the change in the enthalpy than
they do about the change in the internal
energy
when delta h is negative we call that an
exothermic process so the combustion of
propane is an exothermic reaction
an endothermic process
is where heat is transferred from the
surroundings to the system so the system
has gained heat from the surroundings
the change in enthalpy delta h is
positive for an endothermic process an
example could be melting an ice cube
if heat flows from the system to the
surroundings the system has released
heat to the surroundings and the change
in enthalpy delta h is negative and we
call this an exothermic process and we
already saw an example of that the
combustion of propane is an exothermic
reaction
so a phase change could be an endo or an
exothermic process a chemical reaction
could also be an endo or an exothermic
process and even the formation of a
solution could be classified as an endo
or an exothermic process
let's think about making a solution so
let's say that we have a beaker and we
have a full of water and we take a solid
and we dissolve the solid in the water
to form a solution
if the dissolution process is an
exothermic process that means this the
system releases heat to the surroundings
and since the beaker is part of the
surroundings if we were to put our hand
on the beaker and the beaker feels hot
we know that the dissolution of this
particular solid is an exothermic
process
if we do the same thing with another
solid so we dissolve this solid in water
to form a solution
and we put our hand on the beaker and
this time the beaker feels cold the
reason the beaker feels cold is because
energy was transferred from the
surroundings to the system and so the
surroundings lost energy and so
therefore we can say the dissolution of
this particular uh solid was an
endothermic process